foreign
[Music]
first of all what do you think about
we've discussed the Jordan peels lined
up for this and they're actually MGM
were quite Keen
I'm shocked that you even said his name
in general now in my face you play this
back you'll see me going he just said
the name like but
yeah I was told by the original Source a
couple of days ago that I was I was
allowed to
because you said it as if you've been
telling everyone and you haven't you've
told us yeah I didn't tell everyone else
what do you think about that I I
mentioned that there's a bit of
controversy maybe around this director
um and I I wonder if it's maybe a
probably a probably a good thing to be
honest even though I think I really
respect him as a director and I think he
would have done an amazing job
I think the workers would have got
that would have put wind in their sails
sort of thing I don't even know about
that as much as I love Jordan peel he is
the three things that he has directed so
far even though the last thing was very
spielsbergian
are very unique to him
and that's what worried me the most
whenever you started saying like oh well
the guy that might be directing is
talking about a full reboot or talking
about this or at least leaning towards
that and that alone was enough to just
make me not as excited for Jordan Peele
as the last couple months that you've
kind of mentioned it to us because you
remember my face when you said Jordan
peel the first time I was ecstatic I I
am kind of happy that he's not
for the same reason Harry said about the
fact that he he
kind of would lead towards a hard reboot
I don't I've always been against that
anyway
um
yeah I don't the whole thing is exciting
the whole thing is I think that there's
movement the fact is in Europe
is good because they can get around the
whole strike thing
I love it anyway we're going to talk
about the strikes in a minute
I I dropped a bond that that one of the
people I spoke to said there can't be
Studios have said November 1st this has
got to be over we want to work he was
actually talking about um so I talked to
him a bit about it since and he was
saying a lot of the thing is a lot of
the um
uh Networks they always do be like
Christmas specials and stuff and they
normally film in the summer and they
haven't filmed they haven't got them
and they're like we really really want
to do some of these like Christmasy
special type things
um and so the studio but then like the
streaming services are thinking like all
of our next summer Productions they
should be filming now come on sort of
thing so they've sort of said November
1st was they do not want this to go any
further
and are you looking at deadline over the
last two days I think the wga might be
resolved today
it's really looking like and I think
whatever the wga The Writers Guild agree
I think the actors will follow I think
the the deal they go will be pretty
similar so that I think this could be
over in the next week
it'd be nice because aren't getting
official announcements of things the
other big headline they know no
definitive answer on Cinema release but
it is going to be a movie house did you
wanna without saying names did you want
to add that little bit you mentioned
oh yeah well I can say one name uh just
just Chambers the guy that I interviewed
a couple about a month month and a half
ago now on M Cube check out that video
If you haven't seen it yet of course uh
who he is say what can you tell us who
he is oh yeah he's a playwright author
his wife is a big producer at Disney and
has a bunch of stuff going on etc etc
you can look up all that good stuff I
don't know if I should say it but you
got the information a piece please
puzzle together uh but he was talking to
some friends of his he's lived here for
20 25 years his wife is
had the most successful Disney show of
the past few decades so know some people
uh talk to some people at MGM and he was
like y'all y'all are totally right
people are definitely getting Stargate
together
so just just an extra source of
information that there is a Stargate
movie and or TV show coming our way you
know or both this man that name is
chamber Stevens chamber Stevens so no
definitive decision on Cinema how do we
feel about that
book movie we are getting movie
I mean for me it's the most like at
least it seems like it's moving forward
you know I mean that in itself is kind
of a relief I guess yeah
how much time
there's probably more eyes if it was
streaming anyway
just because of how few people now go to
the cinema
yeah
so I know it's a controversial thing
people don't go to the cinema people
should go to the cinema because you
should support whatever you want but
people don't because
money
it's just easier to stream there's so
many reasons why people don't yeah so
yeah going on to a streaming service is
going to be
is going to get the most eyes possible
maybe they'll do both though maybe
they'll do it on streaming and also have
a cinema release which which is very
which is what kind of happened like a
limited Cinema release which is kind of
what's popular in a few years
um I think there's still a Prestige to a
cinematic movie I've done a video
talking about this tomorrow while I was
walking on the beach this morning so I
won't say too much about that but I
think there's a there's a
um
The Prestige to it and like it shows
Amazon are really confident about this
if they're willing to like push that out
but they're trying to become a cinema
production company they want to speak
feature films I feel like if Amazon are
gonna do a cinema release
and it'd be big it will be the bond if
they when they do it
that's gonna have much more that's gonna
have much more of an impact but then
that will be there lots of people you're
right I think a lot of people would get
over there whatever their version is to
theaters these days just to see it on
the big screen and for like the audience
kind of
um communal kind of response I think
you're right I think you're absolutely
right
I think I'll be less likely to get like
an sg1 Revival with many of the original
cast back if they do a cinematic movie
yeah we could basically get an sg1
Revival full-on Daniel Jackson Sam
Rich you know O'Neill even and we you
know Christopher Judge we could get that
sort of film I think if it's at the
cinema we won I think it'll be more
um
RDA I'm gonna scream
when it happens man I'm sorry
I'm asking Brad about that
I'm gonna say that he's then all of you
people that keep telling me that's a
stupid idea if Brad agrees with me
you'll all have to shut up and if he
doesn't I'll have to shut up
so I'm asking them
um
so
you guys so yeah cinnamon
still a risk or you know at least
they're open to it and
honestly after sitting sitting with it
and thinking about it the way we have
the last couple months really
I they need to do a cinema release over
a TV series I to begin with
a TV series feels safe and even though
it's what we want and we want it it
feels boring it doesn't feel like they
actually care it feels like they would
be doing a cash grab just for Nostalgia
and all these different little tick
marks instead of actually caring and
applying that risk to something that yes
has a bunch of nostalgic factors but has
a future
on our screens and not just we're going
to run out of nostalgia quick if that's
all we're going for we have 17 seasons
and a couple TV movies and another film
to jump off of that's we can get some
seasons of fun seasons of nostalgia
but we need a future for this franchise
and I think a movie is the way to set
that up I I think a TV show no matter
what you're gonna be bogged down at
least for half a season trying to
correlate it with things that have
happened in the past you might as well
do do a little bit of that do a little
bit of that leg work in a movie and and
introduce new people as well I honestly
a movie if it was just the occasional SG
person that we're familiar with just in
the background or as a commander
somewhere doing something that would be
great because it it shows us there's
more to this world still and it's not so
much like okay we got actually one back
we got SGA back and we're gonna get
bored so fast even as much as we don't
necessarily want to admit it we would
love to see it but it would just be it
it's not going anywhere if they don't
allow it to go anywhere and I think that
they need to allow it to have that room
and breadth
yeah does that make sense I do agree
with everything you've just said
um I just go on top of that having
cameos from like the previous cast
members would give us reassurance it's
in the same universe yeah yeah it's not
like a reboot it's not um
soft reboot or anything it's the same
universe exactly the same it's just
continuing maybe with different
characters but
that's the link to say it's the same
same sg1 same SGA this just you that you
know and love it's just different
characters now because it's been 15
years
yeah that has to be part of it if
they're just mentioned if we actually
see them or anything I think that has to
be a part of it but I think the good
thing about doing a movie as well is it
even if it's not super successful if
Amazon's already invested in Stargate
which they seemingly are they know the
type of audience they have with it there
is already a baked in TV audience if the
movie fails you can still make a TV show
and still have a money-making audience
there and I think that's the best thing
is because they could bring in way more
people than we have already plus get
everybody back you have something for
new people you have something for old
people you have something to get both of
them excited about new things still
and we just have more Stargate like that
just sounds best to me honestly I don't
I don't know and anybody that says the
um the cinema release would fail I have
to say 10 times gross an MGM movie of
all time the original Stargate the
highest grossing movie of all time
whenever it was released as well
what about that it was it was king at
the box office when it came out yeah
yeah absolutely smashed it because it
only cost them like 15 million quid to
get old get their hands on as well
um
third highest search YouTube searches of
sci-fi shows Stars Star Trek Star Wars
Stargate those two other two shows are
still on and they get searches Stargate
hasn't been on screens for 12 years the
third highest that's mental damn excuse
me Facebook groups there's hundreds I've
said it before the fact that channels
like ours does well
that's not been off the air for so long
just proves that there's a there's an
appetite for it when only one other
franchise that comes to mind that had
that kind of staying power and that was
Star Trek
I mean you know Square gate I mean it is
in terms of all the production the
number of spin-offs the number of
episodes all you know and the the
reaction to the fandom decades decades
afterwards shows that Stargate is it's
in King Modi territory
big big big big thing though
definitely getting a TV series it's
basically already been green lit as far
as we're concerned so
lots of yays
I mean again anybody said anything that
the cinema is a bad idea in a way I
don't care because the steering is
already lined up yeah so that's the
thing like it it is the sleeping China
sci-fi even if it fails it will probably
fails with quotation marks everywhere
around it it'll probably still break
even you know the only thing that would
make it not break even is if it's just
marketed like a mother you know and they
just have it where it's just they spend
three times the mark the actual Budget
on marketing like that's the only way I
could see it not breaking even they they
don't need a marketing budget all they
need to do is tell us
legitimately sometimes we will run our
mouth about it
send me a couple T-shirts
nothing's been announced we haven't shut
up about it for two years
um the sleeping giant I sometimes think
goes I can't do another Stargate video I
can't I've got yeah I can
um but then I just think that's great
that's what I want to talk about Society
that's what I want to talk about
then forgetting Stargate again is that a
big that that's got to be again another
big thumbs up in it that that is again
for an official Source from MGM is
telling us it was Stargate was always
one of the big which is what we heard
way way way ago I mean the the beautiful
thing about why this sources was she's
basically confirmed everything we've
been talking about and she's not really
told us we're wrong about anything which
is just great it just confirms that you
know the people are talking to know what
they're on about and which is always a
concern sometimes when you get told
certain things like
I think you're mental or just wrong but
we just try not to share that stuff too
much
um but again
they've got confidence in this that's
that's what I just can't help but feel
excited about
no they wake up at some point because a
sleeping tonight that keeps on sleeping
is dead it's a dead giant
One Time's got to get up and go weak I'm
just saying yeah comatose giant It's a
sleep anxiety it's had a 12-year nap 14
year nap
um but it's gonna wake up even people in
comas wake up
yeah always
yeah most people they just die but
um I I think we're well passed I I
personally I think we were well past the
will it won't it happen like
nine months ago ten months ago
um definitely marched 100 March I was
just like that's it's happening that's
it now
um
yeah
anybody that still thinks this is
happening I'm just thinking I'm sorry
you're just wrong I mean I think it's a
first-year deal the second Amazon bottom
GM
that's it's pretty damn sure right after
that
you see comments all the time on on
Facebook on YouTube on Reddit especially
when when someone will post not
necessarily our videos but something
along the lines or Stargates coming back
and then they're always just like oh I
believe it when I see it or there's
nothing official been announced and I
think that's probably just
a lot of fans throughout the last 15
years have been promised things yeah and
then it's been ripped from rip from
underneath them yeah
um
so hopefully this time well it will
happen but it is happening yeah it's
gonna it's gonna
reinvigorate their trust in the system
and there are several people that have
put comments on and I've said come back
to me when it's announced and they
better because I'm gonna go
straight up called me a liar and I'm
like I know who you are I have a list
now I really don't care that much but
foreign
[Music]